[Music]
just by way of brief introduction I
think the thing that makes my view
different on health is that I'm a
veterinarian as well as a physician and
in veterinary medicine we don't have
health insurance for animals like we do
people and if we were to use a human
Healthcare type of system for livestock
for instance to be sticker shock for you
your hamburger would cost you $275 a
pound just to pay for the health care so
we learned a long time ago in the animal
industry that we could keep the price of
animal products such as meat and dairy
and poultry and eggs down to where the
average American could afford to eat
them every day simply by eliminating
health care cost that's I think a very
profound statement simply by eliminating
health care cost we do that in animals
with simple little nutritional formulas
that's why we have Mouse pellets and rat
pellets and hamster pellets and gerbal
pellets and guinea pig pellets rabbit
pellets and canned and dry dog and cat
food we have sheep pellets and horse
pellets and calf pellets and dairy
pellets and monkey pellets and catfish
pelts and turkey pelts and duck pelts
and ostrich pelts and on and on and on
you get the picture the reason why we
put all these various animal diets into
the pelletized Farm is so that every
mouthful is biochemically perfect even
the stupidest animal in the group gets a
perfect diet they can't sort through and
just eat only the sunflower seeds the
raisins their health and production is
not dependent on their choices of food
we command them to eat a certain way and
that's the way they eat and we get a
uniform projected expected production
we've been so successful at doing this
over the last 75 years that in the
animal industry we've eliminated about
900 different diseases that still plague
human beings we've doubled and tripled
their historical lifespans in the last
60 years 60 years ago if you're old
enough to remember an old dog used to be
10 years old today an old dog is 20
something uh 10 years ago an old cat was
12 today an old cat's 25 or 30 and we
didn't do that with Wonder drugs and
genetically engineer proteins or stem
cells are transplants we did that simply
by adding vitamins and minerals and
trace minerals to their food and that
kind of excited me uh one more little
thing about my background on a large
Grant from the National Institutes of
Health during the
1960s I worked with Marlon Perkins from
the old Mutual of Omaha Wild Kingdom
days I was one of his veterinarians and
worked on his research project did over
17,500 autopsies and over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 human beings for a
comparison and what I learned was ladies
and gentlemen was that every animal
every human being who dies of natural
causes dies of a nutritional deficiency
disease so since 1964 I've been working
very hard to get the health industry to
appreciate this and not treat nutrition
as the stepchild of Health but actually
as the front piece of health and it was
not very successful so I went back to
school Portland organ became actually a
naturopathic physician which is kind of
like an osteopath in orgon we're primary
care physicians and we were able to
begin in 1978 to use everything I'd
learned in Veterinary nutrition on my
human patients and I'm here to tell you
that the concept of preventing and
curing diseases in animals of
nutritional formulas works just the same
in people these are the sort of things I
would collect to um share with my
patients I I wanted to give my patients
a gift sort of an incentive or a bribe
to come to me as her doctor and I
promised him I'd do everything I could
to get him to live be 100 instead of
75 and this particular issue September
2000 of Scientific American was almost
totally devoted to 100-year-old people
and and what they did differently and so
forth there were articles in there by
medical doctors and geneticists and
gerontologists and nutritionists and
they were all coming from different
directions so there was a summary at the
end telling you what you were supposed
to learn by reading all this different
stuff and basically they were
editorially scratching their head they
couldn't figure out why the people who
lived be 100 were the ones who were
rebellious and didn't listen to their
doctor's instructions the people who
followed the doctor's instructions
didn't make it to 100 and they couldn't
figure out why they wanted to do some
big research project to figure out why
well you don't have to figure it too
long because if the medical doctor's
advice isn't bringing do 100 is not good
advice that's pretty simple you don't
need a $50 million study to figure that
out going back to April of 1992 12 years
ago almost 12 and a half years ago this
was a cover article Time Magazine very
profound article uh I think there was
six positive pages on nutrition uh in
this issue again April I think it was
April 6th or April 7th 1992 the real
power of vitamins and they meant as most
people do when they say vitamins they
mean vitamins and minerals you know
nobody says honey did you take your
vitamin B1 B2 B3 B5 B6 did you take your
folic acid your bite your choline your
B12 did you take your calcium magnesium
manganese did you take your phenyalanine
and your Arginine and your cysteine your
methine amino acids did you take
Omega-3s people say honey did you take
your vitamins this morning and it's kind
of this generic shart hand for did you
take your supplements they Ed it the
same way here because it kind of fit the
layout the real power of vitamins and
minerals etc etc new research shows it
may help fight cancer heart disease and
ravages of agent well back um when I
started seeing human patients back in
1978 as a physician I wanted to have
some kind of animal model being a
veterinarian and a human model to give
them so they didn't think it was some
outrageous thing that I was coming up
with some pipe dream and looking around
sure enough I found a guy by the name of
Clive McKay and he did his research back
in the
1920s and geneticists like to claim him
but he was just a physiologist he
published his Landmark papers in 1935
and basically what he did was take three
groups of rats and and gave them the
same basic rat pellet of the day from
the 1920s which is quite a remarkable
step because research rats before this
rat pellet would only live maybe 6 to 10
months after weaning when they just feed
him rolled oats and carrots and things
like that but once they came out with
the nutritional pellet of the day they
lived to be an average of 2 years and
that was just remarkable for research
well he was the only guy at that time
who was tinkering around with
macronutrients proteins fats and
carbohydrates to see what you could do
to make the animals live longer and in
group number two he gave him the same
basic Pelt as group number one but he
cut the carbohydrate calories by 30%
kept the vitamins minerals the same and
they lived 50% longer than group number
one got kind of excited about that so
group number three he cut the
carbohydrates by 60% from group number
one kept the vitamins minerals the same
and they liveed twice as long and they
thought they had the answer well it
wasn't quite that simple uh when they
redid the studies and pigs and dogs and
monkeys and spiders and all kinds of
bugs and birds and things they found out
that the secret was that he kept the
vitamins minerals the same and the the
secret to this longevity by tinkering
with the food is that you want to have a
high level of vitamins and minerals per
carbohydrate calorie that's one of the
reasons why low carb diets are good for
you why they work to help you lose
weight but also live longer even though
people aren't supplementing they have a
modest amount of vitamins and minerals
in their diet and if they cut the
carbohydrates that means your
concentration of vitamins minerals per
carbohydrate calories going up and
that's the thing you have to look for
well I had a very exciting animal model
that went back to 1935 then I wanted a
human model and I ran into a guy by the
Nam art link letter how many of you
remember art link letter yeah if you're
over 40 years old you remember Art
Linkletter he was a great TV and radio
uh host and he invented the kids say the
funniest things Concepts and he was very
funny without saying four-letter words
so I always appreciated him and it was
kind of interesting and I ran into him
and I was looking for a human model for
100 year olds and he wanted to live to
be 100 and there was all kinds of
newspaper interviews I ran into uh he
wanted to be a hundred and he got kind
of excited about this possibility by
reading a uh
1933 pullit surprise win novel by James
Hilton called Lost Horizon okay well
Lost Horizon if if you don't remember
the book it coined a term James Hilton
coined a term called shangra La you ever
heard of shangrala I think most people
have heard of that and um this was this
mythical place kind of like a place
where you could live in this micro
environment that was perfect almost like
Eden and you could eat everything there
and you lived a spiritual life and you
could live be 200 300 years of age and
it was based on some people in what is
now Eastern Pakistan in a single Valley
called hanza
art linkl hired an eye doctor by the
name of Alan banck to go to hanza and
find out what their secret was because
at the time in the 1930s they were the
healthiest and longest live people on
earth now the most remarkable thing
about the hunzas is they were a third
world country they had no electricity no
indoor plumbing no telephones they had
no hospitals no doctors no pharmacies no
Pharmaceuticals no prescriptions I mean
they had nothing and yet they were the
longest live and healthiest people on
Earth and so AR linkl wanted to find out
what their secret was so Alan banck goes
there and he really couldn't quite pick
it out he was an eye doctor didn't know
a lot about everything so he was very
good about writing about what he
observed but he didn't pinpoint any
particular thing he just says well here
it all is pick what you want but there
are two things that were valuable
knowing what we know about Clive McKay's
animal models number one these people
live in a single Valley at
19,500 FT elevation if You' ever farmed
you know that when you're above the
timber line like that I mean kind of
like double the timber line is like
7,000 ft so we're almost three times the
height of the Timberline and nothing
grows there very hostile environment
they couldn't grow rice they couldn't
grow potatoes uh they couldn't grow corn
but they could grow wheat but because of
the very short and very hostile growing
season their yield was very very small
and there's some total of their
carbohydrate intake each day was one
little chipati bread looked like a
tortilla flow tortilla very small one
one a day per person those are some
total of of carbohydrate intake the rest
of their food was lamb and mutton goat
cheese and milk they cooked in butter
that was it had a few vegetables you
know like tomatoes and carrots cabbage
and so they had a very low carbohydrate
diet so that kind of fit Clyde mccay's
thing 60% less carbohydrate than the
control wraps well where did they get
their extra minerals or extra vitamins
well so happens alen banck pointed out
something that I used to do as a kid in
these people this is a a cultural thing
that they did that occurs thousands of
years ago in Asians and Europeans and
Africans is I don't know who came up
with it first but this been used since
the beginning of time since the dawn of
written history and uh it's something
many of you done how many have you ever
taken wood ashes from a fireplace or a
cooking stove and put in your garden how
many have ever done that okay well he
noted that every morning they did that
they took the wood ashes from their
fireplaces and their heating fires and
they put these wood ashes in their
Gardens every morning well the wood
ashes are the minerals that are left
when you burn away the car in the wood
so every morning they were putting
minerals back into their Gardens now
that that is a very profound thing it
sounds so simple now we as Americans
used to do that because we all came from
a background of Europeans or Asians or
Africans and so everybody came to the
United States in the 1700s 1800s 1900s
with this history but something changed
in our culture in
1940 this was the end of healthy
Americans in 1940 actually started
before that actually started the
industrial Revolution but it was just a
trickle but they they shut the spigot
off for intake of minerals in 1940 what
happened in 1940 everybody got a modern
kitchen electricity Gas Propane are
there any wood ashes left when you cook
with an electric stove are there any
wood ashes left when you cook with
natural gas are there any wood ashes
left when you cook with propane or
microwave no and so as soon as we got
the modern kitchen there was no more
wood Ashes to put into the gardens and
so our source of minerals dried up just
like flipping off a switch and so we're
not eating the same as we did just even
culturally we're not eating the same
just assuming that all our vegetables uh
are as healthy as they were 100 years
ago we're not putting the minerals back
in because we don't have the wood ashes
from our cooking fires and our heating
fires to put back in the land well human
beings need 90 essential nutrients 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids three essential fatty acids to
flourish and reproduce and do well and
repel diseases and so forth
and plants only need nine plants are
very simple organisms I have a degree in
agriculture and I can tell you factually
that plants only require nine to be uh
in a in a state of flourishing and
robust Health but they can get away with
three to give the farmer the maximum
yields in terms of tons and bushels per
acre that's why you see bags of
fertilizer with NPK nitrogen phosphorus
pottassium 10 10 10 10 16 12 because
different plants require different
ratios of those three elements one's an
element the other two are minerals and
we need 60 we're going to get the other
57 well first of all our food plants
cannot give you everything you need just
by eating well plants are very good
about making vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids when they're well-nourished
they have to have at least those three
nutrients NPK to make vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids these are carbon
compounds and plants can take carbon
dioxide out of the air and use the sun's
energy in a process known as
photosynthesis to manufacture long
carbon chains and many of these are are
actually configured into vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids and plants can do
that they can make it and if you spend 8
hours a day shopping and picking out
everything at the perfect stage of
ripeness and you cook food properly and
you store food properly you might only
with the grace of God get enough
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids but
it's worse than Vegas when it comes to
the minerals plants cannot manufacture
minerals if you can find me any plant
that'll manufacture any mineral I don't
care if it's lead I'll give you a
million dollars and small bills tax-free
uh in any offshore account you want
you'll be a bazillionaire soon but there
are no such plants plants don't make
minerals they can't make minerals
they're not genetically capable of
making minerals they get their minerals
from the soil and unfortunately
nutritional minerals do not occur in
uniform blanket around the crust of the
earth nutritional minerals occur in
veins like chocolate and choc Ripple ice
cream nutritional minerals occur in
veins like gold and silver and the odds
of you and I getting all 60 essential
minerals just by eating well is zero I
don't care if you spend a million
dollars a day for food and you on the
very finest caviar and Australian wine
and artichoke hearts imported from Costa
Rica and all this wonderful food guess
what you're still going to be deficient
in minerals as I told you I did all this
research and found out that every animal
and every human being who died of
natural causes died of nutritional
deficiency disease and as you might
expect spending the multi-millions of
dollars actually s and A5 million
dollars to do this research wrote
several papers wrote 75 scientific
papers republish in medical journals
Veterinary journals wrote textbooks big
thousand page jobs and lectured to
doctors many times at their continu
education uh meetings and I was not
successful in getting people who in a
position of authority either in medical
research or the government to get
excited about preventing and curing
diseases in people with nutrition like
we did in animals and I knew this was an
important concept back in the 60s and
that's why I went back to school became
a physician well this came out just
about 40 years later this is a World
Health Organization study nutrition key
factor in mortality study finds life
expectancy closely mirrors dietary
factors well look at there okay and the
most important sentence they had in the
whole article was it says inadequate
intake of three key micronutrients zinc
iron and vitamin A is responsible for an
unexpectedly High burden of of disease
well there's 90 essential nutrients they
didn't talk about the other 87 they just
talked about three vitamins could help
two billion kids this just came out
March of 2004 a couple of months ago
vitamins could help two billion kids how
many people are there on Earth six
billion that's a third of the population
any doctor anybody who says that you
know there's no evidence to support a
claim that you can prevent and cure
diseases with vitamins and minerals is a
fool um how many have you ever heard of
scurvy raise your hand you know can
prevent and cure scurvy with vitamin C
how many of you heard of rickets you can
prevent and cure rickets with vitamin D
what about anemia you can prevent and
cure anemia with iron and copper and
folic acid and b12 and many other
nutrients what about goer you know can
prevent and cure garer with iodine and
copper and selenium and and tyrosine and
amino acid uh what about things like oh
osteoporosis you can actually prevent
and cure that with with calcium and
magnesium and sulfur and many other
nutrients and what about diseases like
night blindness you can prevent and cure
night blindness with vitamin A and then
there's berry berry with congestive
heart failure you can prevent and cure
that with thy and or vitamin B1 and and
then there's a plager with the
schizophrenia and all the dermatitis and
diarrhea that goes along with that you
can prevent and cure that with nin or
vitamin B3 and I could go through all
the 90 essential nutrients because
they're called essential nutrients for
two reasons number one our bodies cannot
manufacture them and we must consume
them every day either as food or
supplements and number two if any of
them are missing you get some horrible
collection of degenerative diseases many
of which are life-threatening and so
anybody who says there's no evidence to
support a claim that you can prevent and
cure disease with vitamins and minerals
is a fool and the last place you want a
fool in your life is your
doctor you have a doctor who believes
that I'd get up and leave I would not go
back to them because you don't want
anybody that ignorant in charge of your
health because well my doctor says I can
just eat well and get everything I need
that was never true but you know why lot
of people in Ethiopia live to be an
average of 29 we live to be an average
of 70 something is it genetic no it's
because they don't have a lot of
minerals in her soil sand let's just
look this is actually a study from uh
just came out this month it's the June
July 2004 issue of Mother Earth and was
actually what they did was take a USDA
United States Department of Agriculture
study where they compared The 1975 to
2004 values in food and when you look at
just wheat for instance the calcium
content and wheat went down 22% during
that time period uh when you look at oh
let's look at another mineral potassium
went down 6% phosphorus went down 24%
then you look at calcium and apples went
down 14% in blueberries it went down 60%
onions it went down 18% and green beans
it went down 33% and broccoli it went
down 54% wait a minute you're supposed
to eat broccoli eat three servings of
broccoli a day eat 5 PB of broccoli day
you get all the calcium you need so it
went down 54% that means you need to eat
7 and2 PB of broccoli a day to get your
calcium yay man that's exciting eat 7
and 12 pounds of broccoli I mean you're
going to generate enough gas to run a
turbine you
know you look at iron here let's look at
iron and apples it went down 60% in that
same time period and blueberries it went
down 72% in onions it went down
62% uh let's see here oh and carrots it
went down
57% and broccoli it went down 33% let's
look at Vitamin A now the V a is
interesting because it's a carbon
compound that plants can make if they
have all the nutrition they need they
have still they have to have mineral
co-actors to be able to make the carbon
compounds right so let's look at Vitamin
A apples went down 40% in that time
period uh blueberries went down 40%
onions went down 95% uh Tomatoes went
down 31% corn went down 400% well I'm
eating plenty of corn so I'm I'm getting
all the beta carotene I need went down
400% I'm eating cornbread I'm getting
all the ba the kerene I need broccoli
went down 74% vitamin C legendary made
by plants blueberries went down 31% uh
onions went down
36% spinach went down
45% they actually check 12 different
nutrients they just get a little summary
here one of the thing I think was
important in this article in 1992 the
USDA the United States Department of
Agriculture came out and said if
everybody just took the minimum daily
requirement of all the known essential
nutrients they're going to reduce the
actual reporting level of cancer by 20%
you can reduce cardiovas disease in
America by 25% reduce arthritis by 50%
reduce respiratory Infectious Disease by
20% and reduce infant and maternal
deaths by 50% if you just if everybody
just took the vitamins and minerals but
doctors today still say medical doctors
still today say you can get everything
you need by eating your basic four food
groups just eat variety have three
different colors on your plate and and
you'll do fine well doctors should be
put in jail for 25 years to life because
it's reckless endangerment through their
ignorant
pontifications they have killed more
people in all the wars and the world put
together it's going to get worse it's
going to get worse this just came out
June
16th 2004 un warns onethird of the earth
is at risk of becoming a desert can you
grow good food in the desert I don't
think so this is a creeping catastrophe
and we're talking about in the United
States they're talking about losing at
least at least onethird of the land that
we can grow food on now there's just no
nutrition left in the soil and so how do
we protect people uh just eat better eat
more
broccoli well that's not it that's
that's not going to work folks the only
wait and make sure you're getting all
these nutrients is to consciously put
them in your mouth you have to
supplement well despite kind of a tragic
outlook here there are people who do
make it to 100 percentage wise is very
small in the United States we're the
third largest population in the world
but are people who live long healthy
lives and again they tend to be
rebellious patients who don't listen to
their doctors they do things that
doctors don't want them to do and
they're the ones who make it to 100 the
ones who follow their doctor's
instructions exactly don't make it how
many of you had somebody in your family
who lived to be 80 90 years of age I
think most Americans have had somebody
unless they all horsh thieves and got
hung early you know most people have
somebody 80 90 in their family you can
remember back they had eat eggs every
morning they' salt their food they eat
red meat they ate their chicken skin uh
they used butter they didn't even have
margin back in those days and the only
exercise they did when they came home
from hard day work was to fall asleep on
the floor and their bib overalls they
didn't even have a lazy boy chair to
sleep in so let's see some of these
rebellious people Ralph Charles from
Somerset Ohio which is in the middle of
the state of Ohio back in uh October of
1999 turned 100 and the fascinating
thing to me about Ralph Charles was that
he was still at his birthday at 100 was
still piloting commercial charter
flights carrying paying p passengers
around the central part of the United
States to me he doesn't look like what
you expect a decrepit 100-year-old to
look like to me he looks like he's in
maybe late 70s early 80s had no
restrictions on his pilot's license or
health papers at 100 and then this gal
here Connie Douglas Reeves four days
after this article came out September 26
2002 she turned 101 and she was entered
into the cowgir Hall of Fame because she
taught 30,000 young women how to ride
western saddles and Barrel race and to
me she doesn't look like a shrinking VI
she doesn't look like somebody who would
say well whatever you say doctor I mean
after all you're the one with the white
coat and the stethoscope around your
neck so I'm here for your advice and if
that's what you say I'll do it you know
she's got her shoulders back her chins
out and she just saying you know knock
that chip off I mean anybody who deals
with horses for 101 years that she's
been rolled on kicked thrown bit stomped
and she's standing straight and tall and
you can just imagine a doctor saying to
her Connie you're 101 years old now I
want you to give up salt we got to worry
about your blood pressure she said well
up yours doc I've been using salt since
before you were born I'm not going to
quit now you got to give up eggs you got
to worry about your cholesterol she go
okay I've been eating eggs forever and
I'm not going to give them up well she's
a little rough for you you might
appreciate Harold Stillson from
Deerfield Beach Florida in May of 2001
he turned 100 one out one and went out
and played golf for his birthday and he
hit a six hole in one at 101 now you
have to have good Vision to be able to
sa that little stick 108 yards away you
have to have a good grip on that club
you have to have good ey hand
coordination to hit that ball right
Tiger Wood can't even hit a ho in one
anymore I mean he's he's done since he
let him do that arthroscopic surgery on
his knee and get that radial keratotomy
I mean he hasn't want to match since he
had those two surgeries he should sue
his doctors whoever talked him into that
I was just in Puerto Rico with my dear
wife and a training thing and this gal
here her name was Ramona Trinidad Eng
glacius Jordan and she turned 100 she
actually died at4 she was the oldest
living guess you call her an American
you know American territory kind of
thing 14 and uh she looks pretty good
for 114 she looks like she's 80 years
old and she lived up in the mountains in
the in the rainforest of Puerto Rico
never been to a doctor and they're kind
of bragging about that in the newspaper
it doesn't seem to matter what you eat
as long as you keep the minerals up and
the carbohydrate calories down this gal
here dor rathebe from South Africa was
born in June of
1881 and I don't know how long she lived
because this is a birthday announcement
didn't keep track of her turned 114 in
1995 and when she was asked Dora what do
you attribute your health and your
longevity to she didn't say I was born
in scrips hospital she was born in a
straw Hut cocked with cow dong her mama
peed in the dust to make mud to smear
all over that child to keep the flies
from eating her how do I know that cuz I
lived in South Africa for two years and
attended many births even as a
veterinarian because I was the only
medical person around and guess what
that's what they do uh she didn't say I
kept my cholesterol down and gave up
salt and went to my annual
physical you think she did all that
living out in the bush in Africa 100 14
years ago no uh she ate Locust you know
grasshoppers not the treat pumpkin seeds
tortoise meat wild herbs dried fruit and
a cup of coffee did she say rice bread
potatoes corn no she had a very low
carbohydrate di the only carbohydrate
she took in was a little bit of dried
fruit and they don't get much of that
out in the middle of the Bush of Africa
that's kind of a special thing people
give to each other
there have very low carbohydrate D had
some essential fatty acids from the from
the pumpkin seeds and she got some
protein from the grass coppers and the
Tortoise meat she may have gotten some
vitamin C and folic acid and beta katene
from the herbs if she ate them wrong
when they picked them for maybe green
vegetables well guess what they do in
Africa I kind of gave you a hint earlier
on every morning they take the wood
ashes and they Heating and cooking fires
and they put them in their Gardens where
they grow their squash and cucumbers and
carrots and tomatoes and cabbage so
recycling minerals low carbohydrate diet
did she have access to vaccinations and
penicillin and all that stuff and great
doctors from Harvard Medical School and
mayo Clinic no living on the Bush
couldn't read couldn't even get an Advil
one of my favorite birthday
announcements is a French lady uh by the
name of Jean Kel Min um in February of
1995 she was documented by the Guinness
World Book of Records being the oldest
living woman at that time there were
hundreds of women who claimed to be
older than she but she was the only one
that had the paperwork to prove to the
satisfaction of the Guinness World Book
of Records the February 21st 1995 she
was in fact 120 February 21st 1996 she
turned 121 February 21st 1997 she turned
122 and she died in August of 19 uh 97
age 122 years and 164 days she was 122
and a half when she died she died
suddenly of a stroke she was up singing
faraka for God's sakes peraka faka
cooking her eggs fell over dead that was
it no nursing home I mean
nothing no cancer no heart disease uh no
Alzheimer disease she was bright and
mentally alert until the day she died no
diabetes
this came out in October when I was in
Adelaide Australia Adelaide Australia
newspaper they have a lot of stuff from
Southeast Asia as you can imagine this
guy here um tiger Hunter Cambodian tiger
Hunter said to be the world's oldest man
has died at the age 122 SEI who is also
a martial arts expert attributed his
longevity in that of his wife long o 108
to smoking and prayer I can go for the
prayer part pastor Joe but I want to
know what he was smoking and if he
inhaled there's also a Sydney Australian
newspaper also in 2003 a Brazilian
believed to be the world's oldest woman
has died age 124 Maria ET Lina do Santos
died of a stroke in Salvador her birth
certificate said she was a descendant of
African slaves born in June of
1878 was she born in scrips hospital did
she have vaccinations in penicillin uh
no she's born in a straw Hut cocked with
mud and since her parents came from
Africa her mama peed in the dust to make
mud to smear all over that child to keep
the flies and mosquitoes from eating her
turned out to be the how many people in
San Diego have lived to be
124 here's a g who made it to 12 I don't
know if she's still alive maybe she's a
gal by the name of Elizabeth Israel and
um this was back in January of 2001 she
was born in
1875 she was born in the Caribbean on
the island of Dominica according to her
birth and baptismal records well how do
these old people have so many birth
records that's because the Spanish set
all that stuff up in
1541 they said a birth certificate
system anybody who is involved in the
Spanish churches got a birth certificate
here in the United States they say well
yeah so and so claims to be 130 years
old but they don't have a birth
certificate that's because they were
born in you know 1905 and they still
still weren't issuing birth certificates
in beanbag Iowa right okay one last one
I think you'll get the message here and
then we'll move on to the meat of this
thing this gal here uh Mizumi Dusty from
Iran back in January of 1995 and this
her obituary is published in the Rocky
Mountain news out of um Denver Colorado
said that she died at age 161 that seems
pretty outrageous but you have to
actually give some credibility to this
obituary because she was survived by six
living children ranging in age from 120
to 128 and none of them had left home to
go to college
yet they were still babies her oldest
son said his mother had never visited a
doctor she never took any prescription
medications she only used herbs dur her
life there's messages all over these
birthday announcements and obituaries
ladies and gentlemen none of them are
just swooning over their cholesterol
lowering statin drugs none of them are
swooning over eating egg beers these are
all primitive people there's Clues here
but what do primitive people do every
morning they take the wood ashes from
their cooking and heating fires and they
put them in their Gardens we have
electric stoves and so how do you
replace what we gave up for the
convenience of a modern kitchen you have
to consciously supplement and put them
in your mouth if you don't do that
you're doomed to suffer all the terrible
diseases you can suffer from now
geneticists tell us we can live to be
well beyond 100 we have the genetics I
don't care if everybody in your family
died at 35 everybody in this room has
the genetics to live well beyond a 100
the Shar version of why we don't is
because we do too many bad things and
not enough of the good things I mean
that's the shortest way I can say it
it's always amazing to me why people go
to medical doctors for advice on Health
and Longevity I have to ask my doctor I
just hear that so many times I want to
choke people and my tape dead doctor lie
I said the average medical doctor
elizabe 58 and medical doctors I mean
they just got so hysterically angry with
me you can't believe how angry they got
with me with that I mean they called me
every kind of name you could call
another human
being and uh reported me to every agency
they could think of and some they made
up and they they didn't want to believe
me which I did a survey I took all these
obituaries and medical journals and
added them up the ages and divided by
the number of doctors got a simple
average and said Doctors live to be 57.6
I rounded up to 58 gave them the benefit
of doubt and they did their own study
came out three years later in 1999 so
wck was wrong the average doctor doesn't
live to be 58 they live to be 56 wck was
a
liar and so why do we go to medical
doctors for advice on Health and
Longevity when they only live to be 56 I
mean it's outrageous I mean you wouldn't
do that in any other industry why would
you go to Mr Goodwrench to have your car
maintained if if the word got out that
his cars that he maintain only went
5,000 miles where they burned up the
reason is twofold I Ponder done this a
long time they have convinced everybody
they're the go-to people I mean you
can't even put on a Band-Aid without
asking your doctor I mean where are the
medical doctors I mean we have to get
everybody to fight for insurance right
because you you there's 30 million
people in America without health
insurance I mean the country is doomed
without health insurance secondly
they've been able to relegate all other
health practices even 10,000 year old
ones like aric medicine from India and
and traditional Chinese medicine they've
been able to relegate them to quackery
they've been able to convince the
government that they're the go-to people
car Packers and nature paaths
acupuncturists aric medical practitioner
these guys are all quacks Insurance
can't pay quacks if a patient goes to
them we got to put them in jail for
practicing medicine without a license
they have politically and financially
been able to kill their competition now
the Sherman Antitrust Act was actually
um put into law in 1895
any industry that does that gets knocked
down my bell tried it and they broke
them up why doesn't the government break
up the medical profession I'm going to
show you why in a second it's pretty
scary well if we're getting our our
money's worth you might be able to say
Well they're Crooks and Scoundrels and
all that kind of stuff but but because
we're getting our money's worth might be
okay let's see if we're getting our
money's worth first of all each year the
entire world spends 2.7 trillion that's
what a t $2.7 trillion do for
healthcare that's a Gob of money $2.7
trillion for healthcare now that $2.7
trillion the United States alone each
year spends 1.6 trillion more than half
so we better rank pretty high since
we're spending more than half we're
spending more money for healthcare than
all the other nations in the world put
together so let's just see where we rank
in April of 1990 I found the first
public printing of where we ranked this
was a World Health Organization and the
Center for Disease Control uh out of
Atlanta Georgia came together and they
came up with this survey they said out
of the top 32 industrialized nations the
United States ranked 17th in April of
1990 there were 16 other countries whose
peoples were healthier than we were and
live longer than we did and yet we spend
more money for healthcare than all of
them put
together the entire world and we ranked
17th Japanese ranked number one 79.1 you
say well that was a bad study let's redo
it well they did 10 years later June
2000 they redid it Japan maintained
number one but they dropped from 79.1
now to 74.5 so this is our chance to
catch up and surpass them at least gain
on them right right instead we drop from
17th longevity all the way down to 24th
now there's 23 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we are
healthier than we are yet we spend more
money for healthcare than all the other
countries in the world that give you
some sense that we're going the right
direction well it doesn't me I'm just a
dumb forarm boy from Missouri but the
numbers don't equate to being on the
right track that give you the sense that
doctors are laying awake day and night
trying to figure out how to cure us of
all these terrible diseases doesn't me
what about all these 250,000
Pharmaceuticals and prescription drugs
they the PDR Physician's Desk Reference
if you take out the 500 antibiotics out
of there out 250,000 drugs which are
designed to cure infections you know
like strep throat and scarlet fever and
pneumonia and things like that there's
249,000 Pharmaceuticals left and you
can't find one of them that are designed
to cure anything they're all designed to
milk the insurance system there's no
laws requiring pharmaceutical companies
to make cures and so they don't there's
no laws requiring medical doctors to
cure people when their cures available
so they don't now that's
mindblower there's no law requiring
doctors to cure people when their cures
available so they don't now we would all
like to think in our heart of hearts The
Doctors medical doctors are altruistic
and they're in the business of helping
people well if you believe that you're
living in la la land their primary
concern is not to help
people their primary concern is to crack
that Financial nut every month Health
spending is hit the biggest surge in 11
years must be Bush's fault God it's
Bush's fault no that started out 20
years ago when we came up with the um
managed care how many you heard of
Managed Care Now Managed Care was
designed to stop excessive tests and
unnecessary surgical procedures and
unnecessary prescriptions by doctors and
it was working but doctor's incomes got
cut in half I mean their Lifestyles were
going in the tank so they started
whispering to their patients look
there's some BDI accountant kept you
from getting that test now I'm the
doctor I know you needed that test and
he won't let me do it you got to pay for
it out of your own pocket oh we can't
have
that and so by continuing to whisper in
the patients ears after 10 or 11 years
patients finally kind of rose up and
Medicare had to back out of the managed
care system and the day after the day
after Medicare backed out of the
controlled environment where the Bean
Counter was in charge of what you got
instead of the doctor went up 17%
Healthcare went up 17% it's been going
up almost 50% every quarter now since
then because they're totally unchecked
it's political suicide for any to try
and stem the tide right now we're
spending $1.6 trillion a year for
healthcare I'm going to show you what to
do about it age 65 Workforce wait a
minute Workforce age 60 you're supposed
to retire at 65 what is this Workforce
thing according to the US Department of
Labor 95% of all Americans are retired
65 retired below the poverty level
$2,000 a month is poverty cut off 95% of
Americans after working 40 years in
America retire below poverty level you
have to do something else you got to go
back to work because that 1,200 bucks a
month doesn't cut it you got to sell
your house you paid on for 30 years to
move into a scy little apartment because
you can't afford the taxes every year
can't afford the utilities the upkeep
what a what a crummy deal well whose
fault is it what's the most common
thread that people complain about when
they retire Healthcare oh H they testify
before Congress I I couldn't eat lunch T
because I I had to pay for my
drugs I I can't eat I have to pay for my
drugs why do you have to pay for your
drug cuz my doctor told me and then this
is the most outrageous thing I've ever
seen last year nine months ago whatever
it is you all remember this vs and
Ralphs and Kroger's
70,000 workers from from grocery stores
went on strike in Southern California
alone and they were striking all over
the country in sympathy with them
because over a three-year period between
2000 2003 the health care cost for their
insurance went up 50% went up from
$6,000 a year to $99,000 a year and the
contract said that the the store chains
were going to pay for their healthare
and so these people struck the stores I
don't know three months four months
whatever it was a lot of them closed
their doors and went out of business
when they did come back all their
customers had started going to Costco a
lot cheaper and so a lot of them are
still not open 24 hours like they used
to be because they don't have any
business anymore that strike killed the
jobs for these 70,000
people they're striking the wrong person
why would they strike the company was
paying their Mor morgage and paying the
food for their kids and paying for their
car payment they should have been
striking the doctors they should have
been striking the insurance companies
they should have been striking the
Hospitals and Clinics I mean the doctors
are really smart they're sitting there
playing cards in the in their country
club where we got we got this Army all
these Union guys out there striking them
somebody's going to pay us we'll get the
government to do it the company we don't
care if they all go bankrupt lose their
job they're going to pay us so I'm
getting close to telling you what what
we do to solve this problem I I gave you
kind of a hint there what do you do with
a failed and corrupt system do you keep
feeding it more
money oh well the mafia we got to pay
them more money they'll be good to us we
just pay them more money Outsourcing the
American dream have we lost a few jobs
in Southern California whoa they're
going to India faster than you can name
them telephone operators in the United
States average $12.50 an hour plus
health benefits in India they make less
than a dollar an hour no health benefits
payroll clerks in Asia make less than $2
an hour no health benefit their
counterparts in the US make $15.7 hour
plus health benefits and so when the
healthare goes up and the union demands
more money to pay the healthc care guess
what the company says Ado Amigo close
the door and they're off to India you
can't blame those companies I mean
they're working on 1% margins of profit
they got to worry about their
stockholders and so if you push too much
it's like the old pinball machine some
of your older remember the old pinball
machines before computers you had 1,800
points left before he could win a free
game and you started pushing that thing
too hard to keep that ball up there what
happened tilt game over I hated to see
that game over game over game over
that's what happens when you push the
employers too much now they have other
options they can just close their doors
and go to India you know with today's
Electronics three rings and they say
howdy how can I help you and you think
you've called Texas you just hit New
Deli to kind of tell you where you know
spiritually medical doctors come from
but they're not going to treat lawyers
and their families who SU them for
malpractice and so when that came out I
sent out a news release nobody picked it
up I didn't think they would but I felt
better I sent out a news release and
said I'll wave my professional fees I
will treat any lawyer who sues
doctors for malale practice I will wave
my professional fees didn't get
published anywhere but I felt good
because I sent it
out doctors say they'd lie to get
insurers to pay 58% of doctors admitted
in a survey that was published by the
American Medical Association 58%
admitted they would lie to get paid for
procedures they didn't even do they
procedures that they did do that the
patient didn't need now doctors are the
only people who don't have to go to a a
bank when they need money at the end of
the month if they need $10,000 because
they went to Vegas and they lost $10,000
they can't pay their mortgage you're the
last patient of the month you're going
to get everything known to Medical
Science they just send in that bill of
Medicare and they get 10,000 bucks in
their account the next day and they pay
their bills and everybody's happy
according to to the Health Insurance
Association of America 75% of insurance
fraud is committed by providers which is
a code word for doctors 75% of all
health insurance fraud is committed by
medical doctors you know how many
medical doctors go to jail for that each
year zero they are dealt with by another
standard if you and I were to somehow
try to defraud an insurance company they
would hire detectives and they would
hunt you down forever and get you in
jail medical doctors do it with impunity
health insurance companies write it off
as a cost of doing business and get who
picks up the difference look in the
mirror sometime you're the one picking
up the difference so we should be
striking them we have a history in
America of doing that kind of stuff we
have a history of rebellion I don't
suggest you pick up rifles and go shoot
doctors although sometimes I feel like
it but what I'm suggesting is this let's
do what we've done in other Industries
you know 60 years ago when the
automobile industry began to crank down
on people look you're driving a Ford car
you got to come to a Ford dealer where
the only go-to people for a Ford car and
go in for a $6 all chain 60 years ago
and they say look uh you you had this
25,000 miles why don't you let us do a
check on it and we'll do whatever's
necessary and you've been driving you
nothing wrong with it sure go ahead do a
check you come back it's a $300 Bill
what it was supposed to be six bucks
well you told us to check it out you
gave us permission to do that it's 300
bucks because we rebuilt the
transmission we did the carburetor uh
all new brake shoes blah blah blah 300
bucks and they wouldn't give you the key
until you paid your 300 bucks but you
didn't go back because you demanded you
know some um redress from the the uh
manager and he said well no we did the
work you got to give me the money before
we give you the keys and so people
started going to junkyards and garage
sales and and flea markets they read
books on how to maintain their own cars
and change their own oil and do all that
kind of stuff they stopped even thinking
about going to the dealerships and when
the junkyards and the flea markets and
the garage sales couldn't support the
demand for parts and tools anymore a
whole industry developed now we have nap
Auto Parts and Pep Boys and AutoZone we
have all these Jiffy Lubes all over the
place they only sprang up because people
wanted to do things themselves and they
were tired of being ripped off by the
dealerships same thing happened in the
construction industry same thing
happened in the remodeling industry and
in the Landscaping industry when they
got a little oppressive to the customers
people started going to garage sales and
they went to flea markets and they'd go
to junkyards to find parts I mean
plumbers were charging $200 to change of
float in a toilet for little old people
and the the worst nightmar is of course
the the one that people hey there were
roofs somehow roofing companies you'd
sign a contract for a $6,000 roof and if
you didn't read the fine print with
revolving interest if you didn't pay it
off in year was $100,000 right people
started going to garage sales and and
junkyards and flea markets getting
materials and tools to maintain and
repair their own home some of you are
old enough to remember back in the 60s
everybody had a tool shop in their own
garage I mean I had them back then we
had a table saw and a band saw and you
had all the drills that's when his home
thing started back in the 60s and 70s
and when when the garage sales and the
flea markets and the junkyards couldn't
Supply the demand for tools and
materials anymore a whole industry
developed to supply the demand now we
have Home Depot and Lowe's and Menards
if you want to find out where
everybody's at this afternoon go out to
the parking lot at Home Depot tomorrow
at 2:00 after church go there parking
lot you can't find a parking space in
Home Depot and Lowe's and Minards
because people are out there doing it
themselves and so there's Clues here on
how to deal with an oppressive failed
corrupt industry stop using them but you
just can't jump from the frying pan Into
the Fire you have to educate yourself we
have all these books Let's play doctor
let's play herbal doctor rare her cure
is Dead Doctors Don't Lie I mean we're
talking about $50 $60 worth of books
teach you how to deal with over 900
different diseases using herbs and
vitamins and minerals and amino acids
and fatty acids we're talking about
stuff that works I already had three
people today I walked in the door just
met them I met lots of people but these
three people came up and tell me how how
the products were working for them they
were just so surprised and happy how
well they're doing on on just taking
vitamins and minerals they've been going
to doctors for years and couldn't solve
their problems before I came here people
were calling me from Atlanta jar from
Portland Oregon dealing with problems
because they've given up on their
doctors and so right now we have baby
boomers coming along there's 80 million
Baby Boomers in the United States alone
80 million who are sick and tired of
being sick and tired they're they're
sick of being ripped off by the medical
system they're trying they're getting
the go you know they want the government
to solve the problem well the medical
industry generates taxes from $1.6
trillion a year the military industrial
complex which the hippies were so
worried about during the 60s and 70s
only generates 400 billion 1/4 of what
the medical system who has the most
power military industrial complex or the
medical system Clinton tried in his
first term in the first year of his
first term to deal with the medical
situation and they chewed him up the
Office of the President with all the
power and Prestige and all the
Departments and money available to the
president to solve a problem it only got
worse they just snubbed their nose at
them not because they were Republicans
but because they weren't going to let
the president of the United States
interfere with their their cash flow and
so we have to do this because nobody
else is going to do it first thing I
want to talk about is exercise with you
believe it or not how many of you heard
that exercise is good for you if you
don't raise your hand you're a liar a
communist or you're asleep already
because I know that you've all heard
that right well this is me when I was 18
years old look familiar didn't have a
gram of fat on me I was mean as a burnt
bear and I I I was tough I was like a
rock and I could do anything I knew it
cuz I knew it and I could in addition to
farm work I'd spend a lot of time during
school and everybody else was eating
lunch I was running up and down the
stadium stairs I was weightlifting I was
punching the bag I was doing everything
I could to get tough and and so I could
play sports and I did and then I read an
article that said there had never been a
professional athlete ever lived to be
hundred so I stopped exercising because
if exercise was good for you there
should be a significant percentage of
professional athletes live to be 100
because they get paid to do it they're
not likely to Slough off and this is a
little chart out of godess W America it
talks about some of the more famous
athletes that died of nutritional
deficiency diseases the oldest one was
red gra died at 88 and now you know Red
Grange died a long time ago right and
then let's see Jesse Owens died at 66
Jim Thorp died at 65 Babe Ruth died at
53 L Garrick died at 38 Wilma Rudolph
four gold medals and track died at 54
babes of harus one of the greatest
female athletes ever died at 43 Jim fix
who invented the Fitness Concept in
America died of 52 Hank gaer is a great
basketball player died at 23 Wilt
Chamberlain died at 63 Reggie Lewis died
at 27 Walter Payton died at 45 Sergey
grof one of the icons of of figure
skating died at age 28 flojo died at 35
I don't believe a seizure killed her I
think something else killed her Don Dale
died of a heart attack great baseball
player at 56 Cory Stringer football
player died a heat stroke at age 27 and
according to the Center for Z control of
Atlanta Georgia each year in America
somewhere between 75,000 and 100,000
Americans under the age of 30 Dro dead
while they're exercising car accidents
only claim 57,000 of those 57,000
177,000 are killed by drunk drivers look
at all the hoo-ha we have about
accidents in cars and doctors are
instructing people to exercise then it
kills more people than car accidents it
doesn't start out your health and your
die how many of you are boxing fans
anybody here a boxing fan okay a few
remember Roberto Duran no Moss no Moss
this is about 10 years ago I think
somewhere around there 10 12 years ago
now not a championship but 100 fights
many championship fights um he was in a
championship 12 round fight with Sugar
Ray Leonard I think it was in a second
round third round something real early
he just got up and said I don't want to
do this anymore they spent millions and
millions of dollars in advertisements
Caesar's Palace and Vegas I mean there
were I don't know how many hundreds of
millions of dollars worth of bets and he
just said that's it no M I don't want to
do this anymore I I don't like boxing
anymore it's a cruel
sport Elite athletes face this Hazard
already talked about this guy van FR and
he barely made the cut on this latest by
Two by Two Strokes I mean they were
sweating him even getting in he's he's
going down folks I just spent weekend
with these guys with Ted and
Angela talk about Talent these guys had
all the talent in the world when it came
to basketball and they still lost they
got beat by the punk team you think they
lost because they didn't have talent you
think they lost because they didn't want
to win you think they lost because they
didn't practice
and if you look historically at this
situation it happens a lot where they
draft some big stars and then it didn't
work you know here's a whole bunch of
teams that hire these big stars at the
beginning of the season to try and make
something happen it didn't happen that's
a little picture of Theo ratl from his
own website theor ratl is a very
interesting guy in um
200201 he missed 79 games his career was
over he had the best orthopedic surgeons
tell him his career was over his right
shooting wrist turned into dust there
was nothing bigger than a BB in there I
mean none of his bones were any shape
they couldn't even put wires or nothing
in there he had the cartilage came loose
in his hip they had to go in do a hip
surgery his other hip was just as bad
bone to- bone arthritis on both knees he
was only 28 years old his career was
over and he happened to hear some of our
Distributors talking to another player
in the locker room he says hey you think
that stuff will help me in three months
time all his pain went away and his
range of motion came back three more
months he felt so good he tried back out
for the team and he got his old position
back this guy
who 6 months earlier was told that his
career was over he had all these
terrible degenerative problems his
career was over well the last two years
he's been the shot blocking Champion the
super super defensive star in the NBA
and that's impossible all those
orthopedic surgeons said so well we put
him back together just using vitamins
and minerals and trace minerals and rare
Earths and amino acids and fatty acids
so I'm going through a progression here
you gone through the emotional failures
physical failures remember I told you
Jim fix was a guy started during the
1970s he started the whole Fitness thing
up until Jim fix in the 1970s nobody but
people who played team sports worked out
the average housewife didn't go in for
aerobics and yoga the average you know
Joe Carpenter you know the average
Working Man didn't work out came home
and drank a beer and passed gas and
watched
TV that was his life his great
excitement was if he you know won a case
of beard at bingo Jim fix came along and
said hey if you run 10 miles a week
we'll keep your arteries clean and and
you don't have to die until you're 100
and he personally consciously in all his
writing stayed away from vitamins
minerals because when he lived to be
hundred he did not want anybody to say
well how do you know Jim it wasn't the
vitamins and minerals he wasn't even
eating Rich bread and he died at 52 of a
cardiopathy heart attack a simple
deficiency of the Trac selenium this
fell here Brian Maxwell was one of his
proteges he believed in Jim fix like you
you just have no idea how much he
thought of Jim fix he thought he was
like another father to him he invented
the power bar there was no such thing as
a granola bar until Brian Maxwell he
invented them in 1983 actually it was
his girlfriend who was a nutritionist
cuz they kept hitting the wall in their
marathons they at about mile 18 they'd
hit this wall they'd have to walk no
matter how well they were trained they
just couldn't go anymore and he was the
one who invented the carb up thing that
I eat spaghetti before the Big Race like
that's this the guy that came up with
that he just died in March of a heart
attack cardium M the heart attack at age
51 he'd won 14 World level marathons in
the Olympics World game
International Marathon 14 of them he
placed in the top five in a hundred of
them in his lifetime and he died at age
51 of a cardiomyopathy heart attack a
simple deficiency of selenium and so
when he died we got on the computer and
we looked up the analysis of Power Bars
it's just nothing but grains and some
honey and sugar and stuff like that it's
an energy bar it's power bar energy bar
no selenium okay one more clue well two
more clues this is a small study only
158 sudden deaths young athletes this is
from 12 to 40 and of the 158 sudden
deaths 48 of them were in basketball
only one was in boxing isn't boxing a
more dangerous sport than basketball not
according to this 48 of the 158 that
died in this little study were
basketball players how many you ever
been to a professional basketball game
well you've never been to a professional
basketball game or even a college
basketball game they have a team a
people with towels and during the free
throws and the timeouts what do they do
they're out there wiping the sweat off
the floor so the players don't slip when
they get under the basket and all that
traffic is going in the basket they're
out there wiping that sweat out from
underneath the basket there another
little clue June 9th this gal here
Rolanda Pierce 19 years old 6'5 Florida
State University she was going to be the
big savior of women's professional
basketball when she graduated from
college I mean she was the big upand
Comer she died of a ruptured aneurism at
age
19 ruptured aortic aneurism a copper
deficiency I we eliminated ruptured
aneurisms in turkeys in the 1950s she
died of something that even a turkey
Wouldn't Die from I guarantee you she
had the finest Sports medical doctors
she had the finest trainers the money
could pay for but she died of something
that a turkey Wouldn't Die from CU I
guarantee you she was just living on
coca-colas and curly french fries
doesn't seem to matter what sport it is
gry Lundy from Newport Beach California
died of 14 of a cardiopathy heart attack
training for water polo this gal here
Helen
moros the top Runner smoke
free top marathon runner in Australia
died at 35 of a cardiopathy heart attack
does she look healthy to you she looks
like an escape from a death camp in
Germany to me I mean look at her look at
her arms I mean she does not look like a
healthy person we talked about Sergey
Groff aged 28 died of a cardiopathy
heart attack The Darlings of the Pais
figure skating world one more maybe two
more then I'll tell you why Reggie Lewis
at 27 he collaps with a cardiopathy
heart attack they diagnosed it correctly
cardiopathy heart attack a simple uh
deficiency of the trace M selenium they
got 12 cardiologists from around the
world the top 12 cardiologist from
around the world and they paid him a
million dollars each to refer this is
the Celtics they paid him a million
dollars each to refer their patients out
to other doctors so they could devote
their full time to saving Reggie he's
their top Financial player and they
wanted to save him get him back in the
game and they were arguing amongst
themselves who's going to do the
transplant who's going to give him a
pacemaker could he play with the
transplanted heart could play with the
pacemaker if they put in the right
position and all that kind of stuff and
while they were arguing about this he
dies three weeks later he dies second
cardiopathy heart attack well if you
wait long enough justice has a way of
coming around right God works in
mysterious ways the chief the captain of
the dream team of Cardiology the medical
doctor who ran the Boston Marathon all
the time he wasn't a a CCH POA he was
the designated Sports medical doctor for
the people who ran the Boston Marathon
he taught Cardiology at Harvard Medical
School in Boston one doctor W Thomas
Nessa a year and a half after Reggie
died at age 48 dies of the same thing Dr
W Thomas Nessa a member of the dream
team of cardiologist who treated the
late I mean I'd have been embarrassed if
I was part of his family that put that
in there this guy's malignant dumb died
sat in his home and pred you know
prophetically he lived in a town called
Dam at age 48 now if your cardiologist
dies of a heart attack at age 48 how
much belief should you have in him but
people say oh isn't it terrible doctor
Nessa died of a heart attack and they'll
keep following his advice
now if he was my cardiologist and died
at age 48 of a heart attack if he said
no salt I'd be taking the top off the
salt shaker and guzzling salt if he said
no eggs I'd eat 25 a day if he said
exercise was good for I'd lay there and
I wouldn't even blink I would not do
anything that resembled exercise because
I wouldn't want to get what he got if
that's what you get for following what
he was saying I wouldn't want to do it
well the hint is of course athletes
sweat more than five years in couch
potatoes doing 75 years you know there's
more Librarians Liv to be 100 there's
never been a professional athlete ever
Liv to be 100 it's pretty scary now when
I showed that to these guys in in Vegas
I mean they really got concerned
also carbonated drinks will increase
your risk of osteoporosis and fractures
by 500% I stood up there on the stage
and I told them if I was a trainer if I
was an owner I would not even let my
players in the same room with carbonated
drinks because they're big problems the
reason why they fall out joint problems
bone problems ligament problems
cartilage problems they're sitting there
guzzling all those carbonated drinks
doctors lack proof that too much salt is
unhealthful this came out almost exactly
seven years ago this was presented at
the annual meeting the American Heart
Association in Portland argon after
years of telling healthy people that too
much salt isn't good for them
researchers still don't have solid
evidence to back up that claim now what
is a good farmer or Rancher put out for
his
livestock salt block or Salt Lick right
there's nobody out in the pasture
telling a cow she's limited to one lick
a day is there I refuse to believe my
human patients were dumber than a cow
and look go ahead and salt your food to
T
salt your body don't worry about it well
how do I know if I'm getting too much
well it won't taste good that's Hightech
answer right if it tastes too salty
don't eat it if it tastes good eat it
that's very simple works like a charm
salt has nothing to do with high blood
pressure genetics has nothing to do with
high blood pressure none nothing that's
the first thing they do you have anybody
in your family with high blood pressure
yes okay you're going to get blood
pressure medic well I don't have high
blood but it's in your family gentics
has nothing to it salt has nothing to do
with it in fact the government spent $30
million in what they called the sodium
task force and this came out in 1997 in
the bottom line it said the study found
that people who limited their salt
intake to 1,000 milligrams or one gram a
day which which was what medical doctors
recommend to you the people who followed
the doctor's instructions had six times
more heart attacks 600% more heart
attacks than those who defied their
doctors and ate double that amount of
salt it's a government study they're
trying to prove the salt was bad they
had to get rid of salt they couldn't do
it because it's not true salt is an
essential nutrient you get too much you
won't like it so what causes high blood
pressure high blood pressure is caused
by a simple deficiency of a single
nutrient now we've eliminated that
deficiency in animals pigs and horses
and cows and canaries and parakeet and
dogs and cats and salamanders and
crickets can all get high blood pressure
but they don't get high blood pressure
not because they don't have the genetics
to get it they don't get high blood
pressure because remember I said we got
these little pellets CU we don't have
insurance to pay for calcium channel
blockers and beta blockers for dogs and
so we just put that little mineral and
all its co-actors in those pallets
called calcium you can drink 50 gallons
of milk a day and you can't get enough
calcium to lower your blood pressure you
can eat 25 pounds of cheese a day you
can't get enough calcium to lower your
blood pressure the only thing'll happen
is you'll be so constipated you need a
jackhammer to have a bow movement if you
didn't have hemr you're going to get
them and so as part of our basic program
the basic program with all the known
essential nutrients to support
maintenance and repair it's a Mindless
thing you don't have to let say I need
two of these and I got my ratios and oh
40 bottles of this we've done it all for
you hundred billion dollar worth of
research we put in those bottles obesity
quickly 62% of Americans overweight 40%
are obese and you know there's all these
diets there's the adkin diet there's the
South Beach Diet there's the Zone diet
and all they do is parse wordss on
percentages of low glycemic carbs and
fat and you know well I I like 20% no no
I like 22% it's going off the stick it's
nothing is touching it well my wife wife
and I are finishing up a book CU we know
the cause of obesity I mean
veterinarians know the cause of this
because when you put an animal into the
feed lot when you put a steer in the
feed lot what is your goal make them fat
Prime Beef is fat we know how to do it
we know the technology to do it and when
you reverse engineer it you can make
lean beef whoa I mean that's mysterious
we've been doing this forever so I got
tired of just telling everybody goes in
one ear and out the other some people
listen take the ferret fat pack lose a
few pounds right but there's a lot of
Technology in that faired fat package
just not another diet caus it's been
engineered to work based on what they
taught me in four years in agricultural
school and four years in vetenary school
and 45 years of experience when that
book comes out it's going to be a
shocker to everybody because it's going
to be so far different what anybody else
is doing because none of them have even
come close to the cause of the problem
they're just trying to deal with the
symptom fat the reason why people get
fat again is because they haven't dealt
with a basic systemic problem obesity on
track is number one preventable killer
oh that's important well here is the
secret of obesity if you recognize
what's going on in that picture there a
work wagon off a little Amish farm in
Lancaster County Pennsylvania
Intercourse Pennsylvania that's off a
little Amish farm and I walked onto the
farm I said what do you feed your horses
oh we just give them ground corn and or
they can get out of the pasture a little
bit of hay well you got a problem he
said yeah they get lame all the time I
want you to look at that wagon you see
anything wrong with that wagon yeah I
heard I heard them say chewed up that's
right those horses have chewed that
plank out of that wagon that's where the
farmer jump off that wagon all the time
with a sweaty hand impregnated that wood
with salt now why were those horses
chewing on that salty wood because
they're minerally deficient it's called
Pica how many of you heard of the term
Pica pregnant women do that all the time
they'll eat dirt that's so common in the
South part of the United States they
actually sell clay in little bags you
can get white clay blue clay red clay
yellow clay they sell it in the grocery
stores because people women pregnant
women have craving
how many you ever heard of pregnant
women getting
Cravings okay any woman who's ever been
pregnant has a craving right that's
because the baby is stealing minerals
from the mother and she's not taking
them in fast enough to replace what the
baby stealing from her we've been taught
that socially unacceptable to eat dirt
and chew on the furniture so we eat
snacks if you're that hungry and you're
eating dirt or you know you're eating
dirt as a kid bam don't do that you'll
embarrass me if you're that hungry go in
there and eat a moon pie and a
RC get them potato chips this is not a
secret
the snack food industry knows about all
this stuff they engineer their the motto
of lazy potato chips is what written
right on the bag you can't just eat one
cuz the engineer when you open that bag
you're going to eat the entire bag and
you're going to look for a second bag
it's engineered for that that's not a
mystery and so if every kid who had
these Cravings you all know them during
especially during a holiday you've just
eaten a seven course dinner and you open
up that refrigerator and you stand there
staring in there what are you doing
Frank I gave you seven course dinner for
Christmas you're staring in the refriger
I don't know I just need something I
don't know what it is I'm just looking
for something because calories don't
solve the problems of a mineral
deficiency when you take minerals you're
not really hungry anymore and so it's
really easy to cut back on the food
because you're not hungry anymore I just
show you two gals this G's from um
Nashville Tennessee an hollenbach lost
90 lbs 11 months good looking lady it
did great and I like this little G ter
Mooney from Fenton Michigan lost 60 lbs
in an 8-month period She went from this
kind of like a I'd say a farm wife kind
of look to this same girl she's only 25
years old but she looked like she's 40
years old Farm wife look at her now and
so we have thousands of people both men
and women who've lost a lot of weight
diabetes is an epidemic diabetes is an
epidemic it kind of goes along with this
obesity thing a million new cases a year
in the United States alone it makes up
12% of the American po population 32
million diabetics of them 95% are 31
million are adal onset type diabetics
and addal onset type 2 diabetics make
tons of insulin they make as much as 10
times more insulin than
non-diabetics it's not an insulin
problem they make more insulin that's
why they can take pills or maybe even
with diet and exercise they can kind of
control their diabetes because they make
plenty of insulin we learned in 1957
where was actually printed published in
medical journals in
1957 that we could prevent and cure
those are two profound words we could
prevent and cure adult onset type
diabetes in laboratory animals pet
animals and farm animals in 1957 with
two Trace metals and their co-actors the
medical doctor say well there's no
evidence to support a claim that you can
prevent and cure diabetes and human
beings and so it laid dormant in human
medicine for 20 years until
1977 and then a guy who couldn't speak
English very well a medical doctor who
couldn't speak English who they put in
charge of a coma Center because he
didn't have to talk to the patients
right they're all in
comas they put him in charge of a coma
Center so all he had to do is read
records and he noticed that the people
who survived 3 months in this coma
Center always got adal onset type
diabetes 100% of them after 3 months
100% regardless of their race their age
their gender nothing mattered if they
live three months in that coma Center
they got anal onset type diabetes they
were waiting they started testing him at
about two and a half months sure enough
they'd always get diabetes by 3 months
they'd give them insulin they control
them and he made the mental leap that
there had to be something missing in the
feeding tube that they were given them
because it didn't matter their age their
race their gender didn't matter anything
if they lived there 3 months in a coma
they got an on so he made the correct
thought that they were missing something
start so he starts reading and sure
enough he goes back 20 years and he
finds his researching animals well that
seems simple he couldn't give them these
alphaalpha pellets with all these
minerals in them because they're in a
coma and so he took that formula and
made it into an IV which he added to
their basic feeding tube and in 72 hours
he cured them all of their anal onset
type it's published in every medical
journal in the world this gets published
every two or three years because people
getting their PHD in endocrinology and
they're studying diabetes they run into
that and they say well that can't be so
they try to redo it and sure enough it
repeats and so they publish it again and
so this is not a mystery every medical
doctor knows this they're not going to
do that because they'll get 30 bucks for
an extended visit well according to the
GAO the general Accounting Office which
is the budget Watchdog for the US
Congress the average income that a
doctor gets off of a type two itic Who
Lives 25 to 40 years after diagnosis is
$750,000 there's no law requiring him to
cure people when their cures available
so which way is he going to go 30 bucks
or
$750,000 now you don't need to be a
rocket scientist to figure that one out
I just talked to the um president of the
NBA Players Association his wife has
diabetes I just asked her one question
do you drink soft drinks she say oh yeah
I'm a Coca-Cola Al holic I have to have
20 or 30 a day well look at this this is
a study on 91,000 women over 8 years
91,000 nurses over 8 years women in the
study who drank at least one sugar
sweetened soda or 85% more likely to
develop type two diabetes than ones who
just drank water or even died Coke 85%
increase you're going to get it if you
drink one Coca-Cola a day it's just a
matter of time if you drink two it's
going to be faster if you drink three
it's faster but if you just drink one a
day you have an 85% chance of getting
diabetes and you know when you talk to
people about oh no my doctor says
genetic whatever turns your crank cut
way back on the carbohydrates eat six
small meals a day with animal protein in
them Watch What Happens weight goes down
blood sugar goes down you live a normal
life well I have to ask my doctor
permission okay last one is arthritis
and osteoprosis according to the Center
for Disease Control 85% of Americans
after the age of 50 or by the age of 50
already have osteoprosis or arthritis of
one type or another to one degree or
another there's not a single medical
treatment design prevent or fix it
aspirin celx bio Tylenol I buprofen
Advil leave meth gold sh penone
cortisone none of them fix it they all
have terrible side effects many of which
are
life-threatening cure arthritis Na
prosis and animals over 300 years ago in
Europe and over a thousand years ago in
Asia so why don't doctors use that well
there's no money in it there's remember
we already said there's no money in the
Cure if doc Smith were to cure all his
patients of arthritis and osteoprosis
today and the word got out he was curing
people the the line would go around the
earth three times and he'd have one heck
of a good month what he do for the rest
of his life he'd be broke because
there's no money in a cure the money is
in milking the insurance program if you
follow your doctor when it comes to
arthritis osteoprosis and other
degenerative diseases this is what
you're going to look like by the time
you're 75 80 years old Yoo and look
forward to that man oh man diabetes back
surgery hip replacements knee
Replacements bone spurs high blood
pressure alzheim disease triple
bypass I'll bet you he was a very
whatever you say doctor now this problem
starts when you're young this problem
starts when you're weaned off of milk I
see so many kids today thousands of them
a month thousands a month oh he has
Charlie hars is he three years old and
he has L crams and doctor says It's
Growing Pains I know it's something
different well you give him any
supplements no are you giving him Apple
oh he oh he loves apple juice and orange
juice and grape juice I mean he just
lives for orange juice and grape juice
and apple juice
well how much calcium and magnesium and
Boron and strum and silica are in there
how much sulfur is in apple juice and
grape juice uh none this is out of
Australia but this is absolutely true I
just like this because the little red
this island of
Tasmania 3ars of young Australians and
Americans aged 12 to 15 are not getting
enough calcium 75% because they're all
living on bottled water they're all
living on apple juice and grape juice
and worse yet oh yeah Sunny D Sunny
Delight yeah it's only 2% juice says
right on the label 2% juice the rest of
it sugar water but every kid loves it
because they got great advertisement on
TV I have to have my Sunny Delight
crack this is the one that really Shook
Up The Players arthoscopic knee surgery
for arthritis is worthless yet the 5,000
doctors in America who specialize in
arthoscopic knee surgery for
degenerative joint disease in 2001 their
income from that one procedure is $1.5
billion dollar why would they they give
it up there's no law requiring to give
it up just because it's useless last
slide this is one you've been waiting
for osteoporosis strikes both sex is
equally since 1958 doctors wanted you to
believe that osteoporosis was primarily
a postmenopausal woman's problem would
you believe or not how many heard that
if you don't raise your hand you're a
liar you're a commi you're asleep
because I know you've all heard it but
osteoprosis strikes men equally with
women how come you men aren't being
shuttled through getting your bone
density test like women well because
doctors make too much money on HRT
Kickbacks and if they were to let women
know that men get it equally with with
women how could you justify giving
estrogen which causes increase in cancer
Alzheimer disease and cardiovascular
disease you couldn't justify it because
I mean how many red-blooded American men
are going to walk into their obgy and
say okay doc I got osteoprosis my family
I want you to shoot me up with that you
know that estrogen stuff that's not
going to happen is it and so that's why
there is no carbonated drinks and give
up fried foods and margins
and cooking oils and me cooked well done
and burnt animal fast just doing those
things you'll have 30 40 50 healthful
years of your
life I have to ask my
[Music]
doctor information and statements
regarding dietary supplements discussed
have not been evaluated by the Food and
Drug Administration and are not intended
to diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease